いやぁ～ヒドい買い方だなぁ～
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです。
俺もさ、USJに行きたいよ
USJに行きたいけどさ～・・・
遠いんだよ
だからもうAmazonで注文して買いました
『百味ビーンズ』でございまーす
UFJ
ゑ？（え？）
ユー…
ユニバーサル
スタジオ
ジャパン
USJか
「USJ」で売ってる本物の、『百味ビーンズ』でございまーす
『百味ビーンズ』ですよー
てか「USJ」行ってみたいなー
行ったことないんだよねー
うわ！
臭い！
こともないんですけどもぉ
はい
今回はこちらの『百味ビーンズ』を～
本当わね～
こう一粒一粒食べてさ、
んまままま
！あ～、鼻くそ味だ～
まず～い
わぁぁぁ～
やりたいんだけど～
俺はそんなね～
バカみたいなことしないから
俺はそんな普通なことしないから。
わぁーすごい
(ﾎﾟｲ)
Σ！、今、
味のシールがあった
色んな味があんだな～
❝鼻くそ味❞ってやっぱあんのか
❝ゲロ味❞もあんの!?
ほら、ちゃんとこういうね
❝ゲロ味❞とか❝鼻くそ味❞とかさ～
面白そうなのがたくさんあるわけよ
でぇ～もぉ～！
僕はそんなね
研究者ですから、
こんなの一粒一粒食べておいしいおいしい言うてる暇があったらさ
研究するわけよ
だから今日はな
こちらのミキサーを使って、
『百味ビーンズ』を全部入れて、
1つにします
混ぜます全部
百…
百種類の味があるかどうかも知らないけれども
も百味ビーンズって書いてあるから
百…
の味はあるんですよ
ココ(ミキサー)に入れて混ぜて～
できたものは～
ほんとにその…
もぅ
百個の味がひとつになってるわけですからさ
もぅ世紀末の食べ物ですよ
もー誰もが食べたことのないねー
もぅ
エクスペクス、もぅ…
アレだ、もぅ
凄いあj
(ﾎﾟﾝ)わぁー
もったぃねぇ～
もぅ、普通に食べたいんだけどー
じゃ行きます
(スイッチON)
(ｼﾞｬﾗｼﾞｬﾗ！)わぁーぁぁ～!!
セプタン、セプラ～！(？)
めっちゃ音デカい。
(ジャラジャラジャラジャラ…)
セプタン セプラー！
(ジャラジャラジャラ)
(ジャラジャラ)
セプタン セプra(ry
(ふー =3)
ぅわーぁ！
ﾍﾟｯ、ﾍﾟｯ
というわけでこれをちょっと熱してちょっとひとまとまりにさせてきます
やばややばい！
はじぃ、
ローン
やばいってこれ
やばいやばいやばいやばい！
やばい溢れ出てるなんか
んーぬ
なんかもう
この世の物とは ー
思えない感じになっちゃいました
ハィ！
というわけで、できました
なんか冷蔵庫で凍らしたら、
凄い・・・
www
ｺﾚ
これ食べれるのか？
『百味ビーンズ』が混ざるとこんな感じになります
もゲ〇ですねゲ〇
といぅわけで！
さっそく食べようと思います
ただコレねぇ、
( 固くてスプーンが取れない )
マジか！？
え？どうすりゃいいのちょっと
ちょっと、ちょっと
なんとかして一口食べれたin
一口食べればいいんだょ
なんかちょっと温めたらかろうじて動くようになりました
でもこれ絶対熱いよね
なんとか一口食えればいいんだよ
よしちょっと、こんくらいだな。
はぃちょっとこれだけ採取したんで
こちらをちょっと
冷やして口に食べれる温度まで下げて食べます
はぃ！とぃぅわけで、
なんとか固まって
温度も良い感じになったんでちょっと食べてみようと思います
もぅ完全に見た目でOUTですね
はぃ！
ではいきましょう
( くんくん )
臭っ！
固！
(ｶﾞﾘ！)
≪ 味わい中 ≫
≪ 視聴注意報発令 ≫
あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛えぇぇ!!!